[Music]
the social scientists studied a group of
farmers and give them IQ tests
throughout the year same farmers same
test but what they found is that these
farmers did much much worse on this test
at the end of their season before they'd
actually harvested crops when everything
was starting to go that towards empty
they actually had lower IQ scores and
then when they tested them at a point
when the harvest had come in and their
IQs went up and so then they were trying
to figure out how did the same person's
IQ actually change throughout the year
and then they ran a similar test on
Americans and what they did is they
asked people a bunch of IQ related
questions and got baseline scores and
then they said hey you now have a bill
that you cannot pay just think about
that and then they gave them the same IQ
test again and lo and behold the
Americans who are presented with a bill
that they could not pay even though it
was obviously a fictitious bill actually
had lower IQ scores and it turns out
that not being able to pay your bills
has the functional equivalent of
decreasing your IQ by 13 points or one
standard deviation and what they found
is there's a mindset of scarcity that's
associated with when you don't have
enough money or you don't have enough
time or you don't have enough food or if
you don't have enough companionship and
it actually decreases your functional
bandwidth is different than stress it
actually makes you less reasonable less
rational less generous and more subject
to bad ideas and bad impulses including
even things like racism and xenophobia
now the opposite of a mindset of
scarcity is a mindset of abundance which
is what most entrepreneurs have a
mindset of abundance is a sense of
optimism that if you build it it will
improve you will be able to get the
resources you will be able to get the
customers you will to hire and find the
right people and abundance and optimism
ends up building unto itself and
producing results if the environment is
right and so this scarcity mindset and
abundance mindset are very much in
opposition
and we're programmed with a scarcity
mindset in many ways because genetically
we're brought into an existence where
things were scarce where if you ate too
much in a particular period maybe you
won't have enough to eat later and so
right now this tension is something that
humans and America and struggle with all
the time unfortunately right now the
scarcity mindset is going up and up in
the United States because people can't
pay their bills 78% of Americans are
living paycheck to paycheck
57% can't afford an unexpected $500 bill
and so if there's a sense that the
United States is getting less reasonable
less rational even more subject to bad
ideas and less open other people it's
related to the fact that right now a
mindset of scarcity has swept this
country because of pervasive financial
and security and that's one of the
reasons why I'm so passionate about a
universal basic income the freedom
dividend to help reverse this trend get
the boot off of people's throats and
replace the mindset of scarcity with a
mindset of abundance with a mindset of
abundance we would see untold new
hundreds and thousands of entrepreneurs
artists creatives founders starting new
things and organizations and projects
and companies around the country because
what we need for that to happen more
than anything else is a mindset of
abundance and people thinking that if
they take the right moves into the
future they'll actually succeed
you